le monde du travail qui fait les gros
titres de l'actualité depuis que notre
monde est en crise ce monde du travail
donc un jeune sarthois l'aborder il ya
cinq mois d'une façon très originale
rien ni personne ne le contrainte à
faire ce qu'il fait il a choisi il a
décidé catherine berra toujours curieuse
d'apprendre quelque chose est allé à sa
rencontre
cet homme s'appelle patrice simon il est
âgé de 28 ans marié père de cinq enfants
dont l'aîné à 7 ans et le plus jeune
deux mois depuis le 1er décembre 82 il
exerce la profession d'homme de ménage
ou comme on dit dans l'administration
d'un homme toutes mains avant il était
cuisinier puis il est devenu la mesure
de carreaux dans une entreprise
spécialisée lorsque sa femme a dû
abandonner son activité professionnelle
car trop prise par les enfants et que
ses employeurs recherchait une
remplaçante il s'est tout simplement
proposé pour la remplacer car faire le
ménage pour patrice simon c'est une
passion
j'aime bien faire le ménage j'aime bien
m'occuper des personnes âgées alors j'ai
pris la décision de de m'occuper d'eux
deux personnes âgées de faire le ménage
j'adore ça c'est un petit peu étrange
pour un homme entend dire j'adore ça non
pas du tout je pense port c'est sûr il
ya certaines femmes qui m'ont maquis qui
doivent trouver ça bizarre parce qu'un
homme fait du ménage fait de la couture
repas ce
fait un peu de tout dans une maison mais
comporte très bien et parmi vos amis où
les gens que vous rencontrez quelles
sont les réactions lorsque vous leur
dites pour la première fois que vous
êtes un homme de ménage et disent que
c'est très bien ah bon alors il ya
certaines personnes qui m'ont dit
au moins c'est la première fois on voit
ça mais au moins c'est une chose
intelligente et il m'apprend va vous
voyez
alors lorsque vous rentrez chez vous le
soir vous continuez à vous occuper de
votre maison cette fois oui bien sûr
quand je rentre je fais la cuisine j'ai
dans ma femme à donner à manger aux
enfants
j'ai fait le ménage eux pas ce chiffre
on suit les meubles comme ici
je peux dire que je fais pas grand chose
lorsqu'il rock sur ton mail aux au
contraire c'est vraiment je mène ce qu
avant je le faisais je dois dire que je
suis pas tellement pour le veinage alors
ça m'arrange
[Musique]